voilà maintenant est une espèce de yvan
attal avec yvan attal et charlotte
gainsbourg
c'est l'histoire un peu vrai d'ailleurs
parce qu'ils inspiraient d'une aventure
vécue puisque quand vous faisiez love et
cetera avec marion vernoux il était
copain avec charles berling et jour
l'histoire dans le scénario l'histoire
c'est un peu approfondis entre berling
et vous n'avez plus envie de boire des
verres avec lui après le terrain c'est
sûr qu'on fait tout pour croire à ce
qu'on joue donc ouais on peut se laisser
aller aux sentiments des personnages
c'est vrai qu'au delà des rapports
tactile c'est à dire se toucher se
serrer dans les bras
s'embrasser dans le même lit il ya quand
même des rapports de séduction des
rapports amoureux quand on joue avec
quelqu'un oui moi je pense que c'est ça
est le plus dangereux c'est pas
forcément les listes
les chaises sont obligatoirement son
père disait que dans l'est sur les
plateaux il y avait un climat
aphrodisiaques c'est pour ça qu'ils
surveillaient ta mère sur la piscine ah
oui mais c'est vrai que c'est propice à
une fragilité sur un plateau de tournage
les plus sensibles et c'est vrai qu'on
se sent un peu dans les sentiments qu'on
doit éprouver des rias une scène qui est
très bien dans le film en question dans
ma femme est une actrice c'est quand
vous êtes en train de jouer aux échecs
dans la caravane de tournage avec
terrine stade et que yvan attal arrive
effectivement on revient à ce qui se
passe ou en train de coucher avec lui
mais vous êtes gens semblent intimité
quand même vous attend dans une intimité
avec terrance teint on comprend bien et
pourtant il n'y a pas de geste est rien
oui c'est vrai je suis gêné parce que je
suis surprise dont il ya un
laisser-aller y laisser aller qui peut
arriver il n'ya pas toujours des
histoires d'amour sur tous les plateaux
de tournage mais puis on vit c'est une
vie intense pendant quelques mois ouais
c'est une aventure alors d'ailleurs et
yvan attal vous l'avez rencontrée en
1990 sur tournage de aux yeux du monde
le film d'eric rochant donc c'est arrivé
une fois ça peut encore arriver en même
temps un pour le moment on se bat avec
yvan tout va bien je l'air très amoureux
l'un de l'autre quand on vous voit
ensemble et votre enfant ben va bien est
ce qu'il est circoncis sept enfants
avaient grandi dans le film sein des
grands sujets noémie lvovsky est très
drôle parce qu'elle est mariée avec un
goal un non juif et elle veut absolument
faire circoncire son fils et lui veut
pas et c'est très bien c'est très bien
raconté c'est très rigolo
ouais ouais c'était un sujet qui
touchait mais vous avez fait quoi vous
laisser circoncire votre fils mais moi
non
vous êtes toujours été très attiré par
la religion juive bien que n'étant pas
juive puisque votre mère ne l'est pas
mais j'étais toujours fait très attirés
oui j ma
j'ai eu une attirance l'âge où ça arrive
genre à l'adolescence serge gainsbourg
lui croyant il s'était rien on lui fait
jubiler fait un nom tout ce qui est
tradition moi j'ai pas eue ouais quand
même
simplement le fait vous avez pas
souffert de ma mère est une actrice où
mon père est un chanteur je n'ai pas
souffert de ça je crois pas je crois que
je me suis même pas posé la question
s'est fait comme ça
non je crois pas tout ça mais seulement
quand même je me souviens c'est quand
ils sont séparés c'est tout ouais comme
pour tout pour tous les enfants
non mais c'est marrant parce que vous
avez un peu les mêmes souvenirs que
romane bohringer c'est à dire que l son
père l'emmenait comme ça dans les dents
les boîtes de nuit à l'âge de deux
pattes deux ans mais enfin des gens
l'âge de 5-6 ans et vous paraît ya deux
ans que je suis dans les bois de l'an
dernier sur les banquettes ça s'est bien
passé pour garder un bon souvenir très
bon j'en avais une vie à la fois très
stable et un peu folle parce qu'on est
suivi ouais et alors un jour vous êtes
sur un plateau c'est le plateau de la
pirate qui est réalisé par votre beau
père jacques doillon et jane birkin dit
qu'à ce moment là vous avez porté sur
l'actrice laure marsac un regard de
jalousie est-ce que c'était une envie
d'être actrice
ou est-ce que c'était au contraire
simplement oublié qu'on fasse attention
à vous je crois que oui je crois que
c'était pas un réel désir de d'être
actrice ou de jouer quoi que ce soit
étant enfant ne naît pas spécialement le
le désir de faire comme votre mère je
crois pas vous avez commencé d'une façon
très très marrante un jour jane birkin
ce sens va et laisse un petit mot sur la
table elie chouraqui cherche une ado de
tournage vas-y pourvoir vous y allez
vous êtes choisis c'est génial
ces paroles et musique plus jamais pris
de cours non j'aurais aimé je suis sûr
que j'aurais pris du plaisir à le faire
mais j'ai pas osé et après paroles et
musique vous avez voulu partir en suisse
dans une pension alors que finalement
votre mère et kate vous disais c'est
détestable il va pas supportable et
pensions vous êtes parti un an dans une
pension en suisse et vous l'avez assez
bien vécu moi j'ai très bien vécu
je pense que j'avais envie d'un truc
rigoureux
vous aviez besoin d'autorité ne m'avait
pas assez la maison s'il y en avait mais
j'avais envie de tâter de la envie de
passer par les mêmes choses qu'eux
ma mère que ma soeur est et de nous
contraindre moi même
ouais j'ai besoin de discipline alors
serge gainsbourg disait en parlant de
good charlotte est une orchidée déguisé
en orties de moins en moins de moins en
moins orties de plus en plus orchidées
c'est vrai qu'avant vous étiez d'une
timidité maladive la volière beaucoup
mieux quand même ça s'est arrangé
si vous vous réfugiez un peu dans le
silence avant vous étiez un peu angoissé
non pas angoissé j'étais très très
timide
je ne sais pas d'efforts pour lutter
conte
on va voir à l'époque comment c'était
mal et auxerre la gagnante et charlotte
gainsbourg
une
ce qui
soum et recycle de m'avoir fait pour
m'avoir laissé faire ceci
claude miller même si claude miller
voilà ça revient mozart en 86 regagne
pas bombarder soutien tout comme sa tête
dans les épaules et tous là vous êtes un
peu plus j'étais très très jeune ne les
classements 1
c'est ça à l'époque vous disiez souvent
je suis pas une vraie actrice comme ça
si si ça marchait pas vous auriez pu
dire sais pas c'était pas mon truc c'est
ça hein
maintenant ça y est vous avez dansé pas
on sait jamais avec ce métier ça peut
s'arrêter
ouais mais à chaque film vous êtes
toujours envie de tout arrêter ou non
non c'est à chaque film où j'ai
l'impression de tout recommencer
si vous arrêtez d comme je sais pas quoi
faire d'autre pour commencer alors ils
vont vous a décoincé qu'en maintenant
pour la prépa de ce film je parle vous à
vous a fait dire le texte à haute voix
il vous et vous ah oui on a eu des
séances de travail très très 20 ans
drôle maintenant quand j'y repense je
suive
il me poussait il essayait de il voulait
que je me sens clip sur le tournage donc
il voulait que j'avais trop loin
peut-être en préparant est de que jose
mais c'était même tueur devant lui nous
et faire des choix
surtout que c'était dans un petit bureau
chez pathé premier long conflit s'était
pas non plus chez vous à la maison
il voulait que vous soyez un personnage
heureux bien dans sa peau c'est vrai que
dans le film d'ailleurs vous est
vachement légère quoi oui oui vous
voulez que je sois que je sois ouverte
que je sois guèye ça ça vous a aidé est
ce que votre psychanalyste vous a aidé
aussi avoue décoincer sûrement ouais
c'est fini maintenant que je sais pas
j'ai jamais fait moi j'aimerais savoir
comment ça se passe non si jamais si
nice pense qu enfin c'est fini mais
certes on vous a fait progresser sam à
samaa ça m'a permis de faim je sais
comment faire
j'ai des solutions vous savez où il faut
aller chercher la solution maintenant
oui vers mes rapports avec votre image
ou simplement vous y pense et plus je
m'en fous moi je sais pas si c'est un
tout petit peu plus détendu c'est moins
grave qu'un d'accord oui ça va mieux
c'est vrai que est un enfant vous
ressenti un petit peu être le vilain
petit canard de la famille vous dit
j'étais entouré de deux de jane de kate
de lou doillon de bambou et vous étiez
un peu malheureuse complexé aux
malheureuses pas malheureux se complique
et j'étais très complexée ouais parce
que je pense que dans ma famille ma
beauté c'était quelque chose d'important
là il ya des scènes dans le phoenix est
parfaite vous savez la même enseigne
ouais ouais m'enfin c'est bien occuper
de vous